bonjour wilfrid fonck merci de répondre
à nos questions comment est-ce que vous
accueillez ce texte porté par ryan braun
peavey bonjour écoutez nous avons
découvert la chose hier grâce à rtt vais
déjà pour la première chose ensuite
lorsque l'on a appris ça on s'est posé
la question de savoir si c'était un
désaveu ou un camouflet pour la
politique qui est menée par la direction
de l'administration pénitentiaire depuis
maintenant cinq ans concernant la
gestion des détenus terroristes
islamistes en prison le texte comporte
des nouvelles mesures dites de sûreté
quelles sont-elles exactement disons que
ce sont des mesures de contrôles
complémentaires lorsque les détenus
seront libérés donc ça peut être des
choses comme pointer dans un
commissariat où tu sens une gendarmerie
jusqu'à parfois peut-être envisager le
port d'un bracelet électronique
donc au delà des mesures si vous voulez
pour nous c'est véritablement la remise
en cause complète de tout ce qui peut
être fait dans l'administration
pénitentiaire au sujet de ces individus
ça veut dire que leur prise en charge
actuelle n'est pas efficace puisque on
est en train de mettre en place des
procédures comme on l'a fait
précédemment avec les violeurs et les
pédophiles le système anti terroriste a
déjà été largement remanié depuis 2012
ce nouveau texte est ce qu'il est
suffisant selon vous est-ce qu'il va
dans le bon sens ce qui va dans le bon
sens ou pas c'est pas nous ils fabuleux
sa justice d'en juger pour autant
effectivement la sécurité
de la société est quelque chose
d'important et il concerne ça concerne
tout le monde
mais au-delà de ça ce texte si in en
l'air il en reste il se limite
uniquement à ça ne sera pas pour nous
suffisants c'est à dire que ce texte
doit s'accompagner également d'une
redéfinition complète de la prise en
charge des terroristes islamistes en
prison et notamment sur la manière dont
on va utiliser le temps de la détention
pour permettre une retour dans la
société où la menace sera si ce n'est en
tout cas plus loin présente en tout cas
réduite justement la menace quel est le
risque que les détenus condamnés pour
terrorisme commette à nouveau des
attentats selon vous écoutez je vais
avoir du mal à vous répondre parce que
les critères d'évaluation qu'utilise
l'administration pénitentiaire concerne
uniquement la réceptivité un programme
de désengagement de la violence qui au
vu du pôle de la proposition de loi a
l'air d'être totalement inefficace si
non madame productive et n'aurait pas
déposé aujourd'hui en prison la
difficulté que posent ces détenus c'est
à la fois des vecteurs de diffusion de
l'idéologie jihadiste mais aussi une
menace permanente envers les personnels
pénitentiaires qui rappelons le ont
encore fait l'objet de menaces courant
février sur fleury mérogis
merci wilfried phong d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire national du syndicat ufap
unsa justice